[Musique]
on appelle ça la beauté du jeu mais même
s'il est beau il est compliqué parce que
le soccer comme vous dites ici c'est
comme la vie je pense qu'on a un vrai
coup à jouer la saison prochaine je suis
désolé Thomas personne n'a rien dit
tu es viré
la bonne nouvelle c'est que tu as deux
options option numéro 1 statu quo tu
n'as plus de job ou alors les Samois
américaines vous êtes sérieux
nous n'avons jamais marqué à son but
depuis que notre pays a décidé de créer
son équipe
encore un mur
et vous pouvez être sûr d'une chose
cette situation va changer je vais nous
trouver un nouveau compte
[Musique]
vous allez voir quelque chose whisky
bière va oui on a tout ça vous voulez
quoi bière et va
je crois pouvoir dire que vous n'avez
aucun talent vous ne comprenez rien à ce
sport
il y a un truc pas
il est blanc
le plus dur de l'île
la seule chose que je veux bien un seul
je vous en prie les gars on a bossé trop
durer trop longtemps pour ça vous êtes
là depuis à peine quelques jours
c'est quoi ça je peux pas bosser avec
ces gens c'est comme si c'était une
espèce de jeu
là on peut dire qu'on fait des progrès
seigneur merci de nous avoir envoyé
monsieur Rangen nous nous sommes
beaucoup attachés à lui un peu comme
lorsqu'on trouve un enfant blanc perdu
dans un sens commercial et qu'on lui
indique le chemin à suivre